in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the aminoacyl-trna synthetase
reaction so aminoacyl-trna synthetase is
the enzyme that actually connects an
amino acid with its corresponding or
with a corresponding tRNA so what
happens here is that the amino acid so
this activates an amino acid and charges
the tRNA so a tRNA molecule once it has
an amino acid attached to it it's
considered charged and when an amino
acid is attached to a tRNA that amino
acid is considered activated
so basically we're taking a tRNA and
then we're adding an amino acid to it
now notice here in this case if we have
an mrna strand that is 503 prime and
it's CUC then it should code for leucine
so the anticodon
on this tRNA base pairs here this g IG
base pairs with v mrna now this tRNA
should because it has this anticodon
that pairs with this code on this tRNA
should have a leucine attached to it so
we need to make sure that a leucine is
indeed attached to it and nothing else
is we don't want histidine we don't want
a glycine we want to make sure a leucine
is there if any other amino acid is
attached here other than leucine that's
incorrect and that's a problem because
this mRNA codes for leucine if we're
adding anything other than leucine we
could seriously damage the protein right
the protein product would be incorrect
so the accuracy of translation occurs
the step Y well we need the tRNA and the
amino acid to match otherwise the
incorrect amino acid will be
incorporated into the peptide chain and
then we can get a faulty protein product
so what does the reaction actually look
like we'll be taking a meal
right I've highlighted the are group in
a light pink color here and that's going
to be attached to a tRNA that's specific
to that amino acid then of course the
amino acyl tRNA synthetase enzyme will
catalyze the reaction and it requires
some energy so ATP will be converted
into a MP and a pyrophosphate and this
pyrophosphate is hydrolyzed off and so
this is the equivalent of two ATP's
being used for this reaction so then
what we get is the amino acid becomes
covalently bound to the tRNA now this
thing is the amino acyl tRNA now
something to note to pay particular
attention to is that the amino acid is
attached to the CCA end over here so
it's specifically attached to the three
prime Oh H of the CCA and because the
three prime end has the free Oh H group
so that's where the amino acid attached
just to the tRNA that's what there where
this covalent bond is so here if we have
leucine we're going to make sure to add
leucine to a tRNA that's specific to
leucine to make this particular amino
acyl tRNA so I hope you can understand
that the accuracy of translation occurs
at this step because we want to make
sure that we add the correct amino acid
to the correct tRNA so that any amino
acids that we're incorporating into the
peptide chain are indeed correct so this
is a very very important reaction I hope
that video was helpful one last thing I
am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email I move University at gmail.com see
the description below for more details
thank you for watching